je
[Musique]
[Rires]
ne payais pas de l arabe et l reprises
et finalement vu qu'on
[Musique]
[Rires]
est là pour me suis mélangé un don qui
n'était pas dans une phase qui va te
coûter 9 versions washington cette
annonce dès le contre on vous met aux
commandes d'un compte au bout du compte
sa chambre au mac il me dégoûte en
compte on a eu chaud comment ma campagne
comme il n'était pas parfait à l'achat
des locaux
non
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire de l'algérie l'une des
beautés de la méditerranée un pays brisé
disant cauchemar est tellement de
questions sans réponse cent mille cent
cinquante mille morts
peut-être plus les algériens ne savent
même plus combien d'entre eux ont
disparu
qui quelle force quelle pouvoir ont
déclenché cette tragédie
avec des terres si fertile du pétrole du
gaz
où vont les richesses
et la france l'ancienne puissance
coloniale les états unis avec leurs
intérêts pétroliers
quel jeu ont-ils joué les algériens tout
le monde tout le monde voudrait
comprendre
les jeunes déferlent dans la rue un
quart de siècle après l'indépendance le
pouvoir vacille
octobre 88 sonne le début de la tragédie
le président chadli benjdid dépassé par
les événements appel au secours l'armée
qui tire dans la foule près de 500 mah
caricaturiste dans la presse ali dilem
est un enfant d'octobre 88
s'attendent vives n'ont
jamais
contestation a été vécue aussi
intensément il n'y avait pas de liberté
de temps où l'âge heureux le long des
sondés par le terroir qu'ils sont
pouvait pas s'imaginer dans 24 heures
après on on se rendrait dans les rues
c'est à dire savoir que malia
matella images volées caméra cachée
c'est la pagaille dans la rue et à tous
les étages du pouvoir certains clan du
fln hostiles à chadli ont visiblement
incité les manifestants à descendre dans
la rue mais en quelques jours la révolte
a débordé tout le monde
il faut lire les gens d'aujourd'hui
seront les mêmes les écrits
d'aujourd'hui même tous ceux qui ont 50
ans aujourd'hui c'est à dire qui à
l'époque en 88 étaient en âge de parler
et qui n'ont rien dit qui ont attendu
qui ait des membres qui descendent dans
les rues se faire tirer dessus mais
aujourd'hui l'algérie s'est tous les
algériens se sont découverts démocrate
le 6 octobre parce que les palois mac
intel démocrate mechta démocrate de plus
de 25 ans ou là de thau longtemps dans
la rue j'ai vu que des gamins j'ai vu
tous des gamins
[Musique]
précédé par de grandes grèves ouvrières
octobre 88 sonne comme un acte
d'accusation
qu'avez vous fait de ce pays disent ces
jeunes qui s'attaquent en priorité au
bâtiment du pouvoir
y avait beaucoup de rage
il y avait beaucoup de rage contre le
pouvoir parce qu'il faut dire que nous
pouvoir
représenter le déni de liberté à tout un
peuple
mustapha brami est alors très actif à
l'université d'alger au bout de quelques
jours les islamistes comme lui qui me
lie de la clandestinité depuis des
années tente de s'approprier les
manifestations nous nous sommes dits
nous ne pouvons absolument pas être à la
traîne
de ce mouvement nous devons absolument
appuyer toutes ces revendications qui
tendent à libérer l peuple les
islamistes entre en scène parmi eux ali
belhadj un jeune prof de collège se fait
remarquer à la mosquée kaboul à alger
ses prêches virulents attaque le pouvoir
et galvanise les fidèles
[Musique]
face à cette révolte le gouvernement est
paralysé le général benny et laisse
ministre auprès de chadli réalise le
fossé creusé entre la société et le
pouvoir il va démissionner
devant donc le
l'incapacité des forces de l'ordre
habituel police et gendarmerie à faire
face à la situation on a fait appel à
l'armée mais là mais elle même avait
encore moins d'expérience dans ce
domaine là que les forces de sécurité
et ceux qui étaient à la tête de cette
armée n'avait n'avait d'autres moyens
d'intervenir que de faire venir les
unités de combat en se risquant dans
l'armée nationale populaire
l'insurrection il ya un seul moyen c'est
connu à travers le monde entier
c'est de maintenir l'ordre
maintenir l'ordre c'est utiliser la
troupe donc l'état tient à déclarer par
le président a aidé m'a désigné
responsable pour alger cet ancien
sous-officier de l'armée française va
devenir l'un des hommes forts de
l'algérie
est la bête noire des islamistes
khaled nezzar devient un homme clé en
octobre 88 quand le président shady
l'appel pour réprimer les émeutes
ont commencé par des manifestations
monstres
des manifestations de plus de 50 milles
jusqu'à 75 kg malgré que à l'époque il y
avait l'état de siège et interdictions
interdiction de de se rassembler parce
que l'essentiel c'est ça il y a
interdiction de s'assembler
utilisation d armes uniquement pour
faire dispenser déjà et dans des normes
bien
réglementée à savoir retire pas pour
tuer en tir pour faire disperser on
désigne le chef des études à tirer dans
les jambes après avoir dans les
distributions pour faire disperser les
gens c'est tout le malheur c'est que
déjà la tourbe qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude au bain tiède board qui
reçoit par terre swann et c'est là où ça
fait le plus de dégâts
parce que tient par terre vous avez deux
projectiles au lieu d'un vous avez
l'enveloppent
qui est à l'état qui parle d'un côté et
vous avez le noyau dassier qui parle de
l'autre devant une foule c'est là où ça
fait des dégâts aujourd'hui vous vous
dites notre riposte était
disproportionnée par rapport à la nature
des événements
non je ne dirais pas disproportionnée je
dirais que je regrette bien sûr
qu'il y ait eu des morts mais il n'y
avait pas moyen de faire autrement
[Musique]
l'armée nationale populaire la nba a
tiré sur le peuple la société sous le
choc et le régime discrédité
mais octobre 88 va libérer la parole
bravant la censure des journalistes
courageux vont parler malgré la sécurité
militaire la redoutable police politique
du régime
en fait très rapidement la concernant
est temps de parler de deux morts et de
torture et là on décide une amie
journaliste et moi baisse mais moi
d'aller enquêter certains services de
sécurité
n'ayant pas été capables de de désigner
des responsables de l'émeute étant
persuadé qu'il y avait une main
étrangère je lis bien une main étrangère
un complot étranger derrière ces
événements ont procédé à des
arrestations massives
et on s'est essayé de faire parler les
gens
sous la contrainte sur la torture pour
remonter à la source on faisait passer
l'électricité au niveau d'une pièce
qu'ils ont sonné la salle de tortis vis
à vis des sites à 6 à 7 personnes dont
nous accrocher tout nu sur un sommet
avec métallique avec des menottes vous
versez de l'eau pratiquement tout sur
tout notre corps pour qu'ils soient bons
conducteurs
et
bush est pratiquement nous mettez dans
la bouche
des
visites les témoignages de cet
enseignant et de dizaines d'autres
victimes de la torture militants de
gauche jeunes manifestants islamistes
sont publiés dans un recueil mais ce cas
inward octobre restera sans conséquence
[Musique]
le pouvoir a très bien vécu avec le
quesnoy le quesnoy nous a servi que
comme instrument de
réunir de mobilisation d'opinion mais du
point de vue juridique n'en a eu aucune
le fln ne peut plus parler au nom du
peuple
la génération qui a pris le pouvoir en
62 est au pied du mur
si le président chadli veut sauver sa
peau et sauver le système c'est toute la
maison fln qu'il doit rénover
et majette mashakado
noël
charlie le disent quand il est venu
parler de division à la constitution
multipartisme n'a su ni d'un conte n'a
jamais revendiqué à
10 h à 10 h
maria
mais franchement un jour on n'avait pas
de conscience politique et après avoir
encore une fois on n'était pas là pour
dire que voilà ce qu'on veut non on
savait ce qu'on voulait plus
ce dont les jeunes ne veulent plus
c'est de cette algérie de papa cette
algérie qui sait dresser fièrement 60,2
mais qui n'a pas tenu ses promesses
au sortir de la guerre contre la france
l'algérie est libre mais exsangue la
colonisation a divisé la société
elle l'a détruite ou plus profond en
1962 elle compte neuf millions
d'habitants et seulement 750 étudiants
alger la joie de l'indépendance est de
courte durée en coulisses on se bat pour
le pouvoir les politiques du
gouvernement provisoire sont écartés par
les militaires de l'armée de libération
nationale
l'algérie est mal parti
le président ben bella collé par son
ministre de la défense rue wéry
boumédiène sauvegarde les apparences
d'un pouvoir civil
l'état algérien n'a pas de l'iso de
d'héritage dynastique ou
monarchique il est issu du droit à
l'autodétermination et des instants où
ce droit a été confisqué il ay ay
légitimité originel et les conséquences
de cela a été la confiscation de toutes
les libertés d'expression d'organisation
de participation aux algériens et
algériennes le rêve les algériens
c'était à la fois la liberté et
l'égalité
avec benbella boudiaf et d'autres qui
avaient été emprisonnés par la france
hocine aït ahmed et l'un des leaders
historiques de la lutte pour
l'indépendance avec boudiaf il figurera
longtemps parmi les principaux opposants
du pouvoir algérien il puise son combat
en kabylie une région frondeuse qui a sa
propre langue et sa culture
ben bella est renversé par le numéro un
de l'armée à houari boumédiène avec ce
coup d'état le ton est donné tous les
dirigeants historiques qui avaient une
autre vision de l'algérie ont tous été
écartés vous demandez est ce que les
étudiants pensent de ce qui s'est passé
à alger ces pompiers
c'est pour la télévision france
télévisions françaises et bien je peux
vous dire que les étudiants ils passent
beaucoup de mal ce qui se passe mal et
là vous considérez que cette prise de
pouvoir du coloré actionnaire qu'est ce
que ça veut dire les actionner
typiquement fasciste par la manière dont
ça s'est fait
fascistes dans la manière mais peut-être
pas fasciste dans l'est dans lesquelles
sa part les schistes dans la manière les
prolongements obligatoirement suivre
notre armée
aura une mission à accomplir
c'est à dire la participation
effective
à la construction
de notre pays
au début c'est l' enthousiasme la
révolution agraire les terres
collectiviser et l'industrie
industrialisante colombier joliment
semble riche de promesses mais très vite
on deschamps les grands complexes
industriels sur le mode socialistes se
révèlent totalement inadapté aux besoins
l'agriculture est littéralement cassé
houari boumédiène l'ensm l'autre grand
chantier l'arabisation de l'éducation
l'algérie indépendante veut s'affranchir
du passé colonial et donc de la langue
française taleb ibrahimi ministre de
l'éducation sera l'un des promoteurs de
cette politique
je suis très fier de ce que j'ai fait
pour la culture de de mon pays j'ai fait
peu avec les moyens du bord et je n'ai
jamais avancé d'un pas sans préparer les
moyens jamais dans la binationalité
chômage si le niveau était faible le
niveau de tous nos enseignants étaient
faibles c'est le résultat de 130 ans de
mission civilisatrice française mais
l'algérie nouvelle n'a pas assez de
professeurs alors on fait venir des
enseignants des pays frères des
coopérants souvent médiocre la démarche
du pouvoir
qui concerne l'école n'est pas une
démarche de culture un pays vaut ce que
vaut sa son école or l'école algérienne
a été fait a été fait d'une manière
démagogique
c'était une démarche revanchard sur la
langue française revanchard de la part
de qui de la part d
deux des gouvernants de ceux qui ont
pris le pouvoir de ceux là même qui
envoyaient leurs enfants vers les
universités occidentales
l'algérie est riche d influence et son
identité ne se résume pas seulement à
l'islam et à l'arabité une région la
kabylie va le rappeler fortement au
printemps 80 en se révoltant pour
défendre sa culture
je dis toujours qu'un véritable algérien
est celui chez qui coexistent
harmonieusement la berbérité l'arabité
et l'islamité et si vous touchez une de
ses composantes vous voulez l'occulté se
développe le berbérisme se développe
l'arabisme se développe l'islamisme
certains disent pour que la révolution
soit piges il faut qu'elle soit l'unc
s'est pas tout à fait quand je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord
c'est pas tout à fait d'accord c'est
cette définition il ne faut pas
remplacer d'anciens t'en fait pas de
nouveaux prophètes à choisir je le dis
j'ai toujours dit entre
notre prophète
entre
est de nouveau présente en fait
malheureusement pas semaines à partir du
moment où on a reconnu les siens comme
religion d'état
bien l'islam en tant que religion n'a
pas échappé à l'instrumentalisation
systématique par le pouvoir les mosquées
étaient devenus comme au temps de la
colonisation de tremplin pour la peau
pour la propagande du régime
cette algérie déjà fragile sur ses bases
et désemparés à la mort de boom est il
plutôt que le préféré du président le
jeune ministre des affaires étrangères
bouteflika l'armée désigne un candidat
qui ne fait d'ombré à personne le
colonel chadli bendjedid ce militaire
aux cheveux blancs qu'elle mérite d'être
le plus ancien gradé pendant trente ans
on a toujours choisi
choisi le candidat
pour la présidence à partir de là mais
c'est comme si la météo froide ans c'est
pareil quand le président a été désigné
à partir de là mais parce c'est lé
régime révolutionnaire
koné président a élé vous savez comment
ça se passe dans un parti unique
dans un parti ni corps on désigne
quelqu'un celui qui est le cas le plus
malléable et puis les chefs dont il est
président et devient président donc
c'est léger bo du sceau d'un d'autant
qu'il est désigné paquet par le fn est
tenu par qui a des anciens de la l1
avec chadli l'institution présidentielle
perd de son brio le nouveau président
travaille peu et s'entoure mal le parti
unique est devenue un appareil
bureaucratique poussiéreux qui paralyse
le pays les grandes messes rituel comme
les congrès du fln montrent une unité de
façade
mais dans les coulisses du pouvoir
les clans se font et se défont au gré
des intérêts des commissions à
l'exportation et des amitiés régionales
l'économie tourne au ralenti la
population qui a explosé en vingt ans
affluent vers les villes mais surtout la
corruption gangrène les sommets du
pouvoir les nouveaux riches sont
arrogants leur fortune trop visible le
pétrole et le gaz s'ils coffre-fort de
l'algérie 90% à eux seuls des
exportations le premier avertissement
arrivants 86 qu'en chute le prix du
pétrole
tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour
que l'algérie explose à la fin des
années 80
à chaque crise économique comme en
octobre 88 la jeunesse investi la rue
elles représentent 70% de la population
algérienne
[Musique]
pas de travail pas de logement décent
c'est le d'égouttage comme ils disent
[Musique]
des années dans la bijouterie adhère
tout cas n'est pas de la
liberté d'expression
tarde pas trop mal mais
logent déjà présents à dubaï
est important de savoir à
quoi se résume le caire faisant croire
que je n'ai pas été très content je vois
là c'est un projet à la montat congé
les aider
pratiquement tout est là je me rends
série
roma
roma et d'un tournoi où elle conseille d
et vernir palic mélomanes
visas demandés
aux manettes
que répondre à cette jeunesse
après le séisme d'octobre 88 le
président chadli va changer radicalement
de politique ouverture économique fin du
parti unique
l'armée observe en retrait l'homme des
réformes le premier ministre ou le tram
rouges venaient avec une ouverture
politique à ce moment là c'était la
grande erreur
on vient avec d'ouverture politique à un
moment où le pays étant si vous voulez
en position d'affronter la démocratie de
faire face d'accepter cette démocratique
je pense qu'il y a eu je dirais une
ouverture par effraction c'est à dire
que l'armée n'a pas suivi
cette espèce de communion qu'il y avait
entre les réformateurs et le chef de
l'état il ya eu donc cette ouverture et
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai réagi
jeudi il faut que je rentre en algérie
l'algérie semble alors se réconcilier
avec son passé les jeunes de 20 ans
découvre les visages de ces héros de
l'indépendance qui ont été effacées des
livres d'histoire
longtemps exilé en suisse l'ancien
président ben bella tout comme ait matin
attendent beaucoup de ce prétend
démocratique des dizaines de journaux
sont créés tout le monde sort dans la
rue des islamistes à l'extrême gauche et
puis aussi les femmes qui se battent au
premier rang
demandant l'abrogation du code de la
famille qui est totalement
inconstitutionnelle et nous demandons de
vivre comme citoyenne libre égal en
droits et en devoirs avec les hommes et
dans le cadre de lois l'histoire
constitutionnelle
tout le monde voulait faire son journal
tout le monde voulait faire ça son
périodique tout le monde voulait faire
son hebdomadaire et je crois que ça
reste une période
une période d'âge d'or si on peut
s'exprimer ainsi delà de la presse
privée de la presse indépendante en
algérie il y avait pour tous les goûts
il y avait pour toutes les couleurs il y
avait pour tous les temps il y avait
pour toutes les tendances ce qui était
le plus urgent c'était de faire vite de
sortir des journaux avant que le pouvoir
ne change d'avis et donc c'était une
course contre la montre
même la radio télévision d'état l'unique
comme disent les algériens pour se
moquer d'elle s'ouvre débat
de liberté sur les antennes d'une radio
je peux dire que tout le monde apprenait
les uns des autres et personne n'avait
la recette que leurs mains ou
l'expérience derrière lui pour dire
voilà que ces télévisions pluralise une
radio ou un journal donc nous avons tous
appris en marchant le temps que ça dure
[Musique]
rires
il est passé
lee
quatre vingts terrassé
je dis voilà moi je fais des réformes
moi je fais pas une télévision service
du rafale m lequel était encore seul
parti dominant car symboliquement vous
fait fermer le bureau du fln je le ferme
physiquement je change les serrures de
nuit et je le remets leurs affaires dans
des cartes en bien à l'abri et je ferme
le bureau de ce qu'on appelait les bsb
les bureaux de surveillance et de je
suis pas quoi de prévoyance et pas
comment ils appelaient ça qu'ils étaient
les dix ans le nez les yeux de la police
à l'intérieur de toutes les entreprises
publiques
m
ne pas crier
[Musique]
et c'est tout
et à
le fln qui est maintenant aux mains des
rénovateurs soutient les réformes mais
le gouvernement peine à bousculer
l'ancien système l'ouverture politique
et économique qui menace les profiteurs
du système à trop tarder elle se fait
dans la plus grande confusion
dans la crise près de 60 partis sous
l'eau près de 60 partis comme disent les
algériens soient steen facebook c'est un
résident ça veut dire 60 versets du
coran il ya soixante
hier un seul parti nous a fait un mal
terrible aujourd'hui ses 60 parties mais
un parti un seul va bouleverser l'avenir
de l'algérie profitant de l'ouverture
les islamistes sort de la clandestinité
divisée autour de plusieurs chefs
religieux ils réussissent quand même à
créer un large front islamique abassi
madani presque timide face aux
journalistes annoncent la naissance du
fils est en quête d'elle
mais l'affairé
n'est
pas chaud
[Musique]
le réseau
abc madani a fait autrefois un passage
au fln et un détour par la prison pour
ses activités militantes
c'est un politique rusé qui connaît les
rouages du système
le numéro deux du fils ali ben hadj est
plus violent dans ses prêches il
représente le courant radical qu'on
appelle salafistes qui a pour objectif
l'application de la charia la loi de
dieu m'a nadal
à qui il accorde
vialli
fait
bouger le quartier de wazemmes et imad
et de quelle nationalité crosby son mari
m'aide à caen tout cas la vidéo la télé
et qui ya un man à nous [__] la
trouille islamique
nanou deauville à tous
jj hardy work des matchs phillies a dit
akbar d'y aménager a dit ce qu'il veut
elio ouanna tiberkanine journée at
minois ringard l'eeetop mcafee ville a
dit elle il s'agit de ce trimestre
dernier deal de ghislaine à l'islam y
biroulet quintana vide ou un tapis de
la marque
à moi mais à j ai tarifs pas manager
camp libéral je disais dans certains
prêchent la démocratie est un pis
comment réagissez vous
ceci est un autre débat
ceci est un autre débat si on ne prend
que la démocratie que dans un sens que
dans son soubassement idéologique à
savoir que le la souveraineté appartient
au peuple il y à un débat religieux qui
semblent pas à ce constat là pour nous
musulmans la souveraineté n'appartient
qu'à halak à dieu et à lui seul la
souveraineté n'appartient pas au peps
pourquoi alors que curieusement l'arrco
région dirige à l'arrivée de taj et
rethel qui disait que si on ne reconnaît
pas il va se développer sans nous et il
va se développer dans une sorte de
clandestinité suture elle qui plus
dangereux tandis que si on le connaît il
va être au grand rôle et là on pourra le
combattre ce n'est pas vrai
négociateur des accords d'evian qui ont
mis fin à la guerre d'algérie cet ancien
diplomate deviendra premier ministre en
canal et elle nous avions gardé les
réflexes de la clandestinité
on avait la demande des parties sma
nous étions entre la clandestinité la
transparence
nous avions des doutes quant à la
sincérité du couvent à
kemmel guemazi qui sera élu maire
d'alger est l'un des fondateurs du fils
l'islam politique est un courant qui a
toujours existé à l'intérieur même du
fln mais les islamistes sont développées
aussi clandestinement de multiples
réseaux
au début des années 80 un premier maquis
islamiste a même défié les autorités son
chef mustapha bouyali est un ancien
combattant du fln avant même la création
du fils des islamistes organiser des
camps d'entraînement l'été sur les
plages au vu et au su des autorités
déjà se sont pas taillés bien avant
que ce soit sur plans d'eau et bords que
ce soit sur le plan de la préparation
militaire
la préparation pour faire face aux
services de sécurité puisqu'on leur a
indiqué dans ses manuels quand vous êtes
arrêté voilà ce qui ferait pas défaut
tenir dans deux jours avant de dire la
vérité si vous êtes portugais et
institutions
et reprenez un peu les mêmes y aller
même si vous les habitués ou les bonnes
manières du fln à l'époque à l'époque et
en même temps déjà été envoyés en
afghanistan
discrètement été envoyés en afghanistan
savait pas où est passé
ce sont des centaines d'algériens
histoire à peshawar au pakistan une
maison de l'algérie accueille même les
volontaires pour entrer dans les réseaux
de ben laden de retour à alger ils
prendront les armes et participeront
plus tard à la création du gia groupe
islamique armé tous les mouvements
islamistes est la plupart a été créée
sous l'instigation des états unis
d'amérique et tous les allées par
exemple l'afghanistan des volontaires
qui allait en afghanistan de la base
logistique situé dans la baie saoudite
et donc pendant longtemps des américains
ont vécu avec cette idée là que
l'islamisme après tout va
découvrir tout allait bien jusqu'au
moment où ils ont compris la réalité de
l'islam qui étude internationale qui non
seulement n'est pas l'allié des états
unis mais qui est consubstantiellement
l'ennemi juré des états unis pourquoi
parce que le fonds de commerce
mais c'est l'anti occidentalisme les
mouvements fondamentalistes dans le
monde musulman où on est et
antimarxistes anti communiste
anti nassérien donc il ya une sorte de
d'erreur de vision c'est pour ça que les
les américains une époque soutenait les
frères musulmans est un peu la matrice
beaucoup d'autres mouvements après parce
qu'au moins ils étaient anti
nationalisme arabe elle nationalisme
arabe était dangereux pour israël ont
été dangereux pour les intérêts
pétroliers donc c'est une des sources de
cette de cette sympathie et ronge sinon
cette complaisance étrange pour beaucoup
de mouvement de ce type
on a vu ce phénomène émergé après
l'expulsion des soviétiques
d'afghanistan
certains islamistes ou des groupes
d'islamistes qui avait participé à la
guerre contre les russes sont retournés
chez eux puis ont mené une lutte armée
contre leurs propres régimes
certainement pas l'intention des
etats-unis
rétrospectivement je pense que les états
unis auraient dû être plus conscients de
cela et plus impliqué pour empêcher
l'apparition de ce que l'on appelle les
afghans d'afrique du nord
afghan mais là dessus ça veut dire que
le pouvoir algérien de l'époque savaient
que des algériens savent et ne faisait
absolument rien du tout voilà le
problème
normalement un algérien ne peut pas
comme ça de lui même partir guerroyer
dans un autre pays
il le savait plus ou moins mais rien et
était à l'époque pourquoi sfr
je veux dire par la suite en fait
pourquoi on a laissé faire on a laissé
faire aussi d'office donc c'est pas
uniquement la fed l'avocat des stars
puisqu'on a des effets devises chedli
reçoit maintenant le chef du fils comme
un invité obligé du pouvoir pourtant les
chefs d'état du maghreb s'était promis
de ne légalise et aucun parti cela
l'epa lors de cette réunion le président
chadli a présenté des garanties
des garanties qui concernait les
réformes
du multipartisme les droits de l'homme
ainsi que le calendrier des élections
communales
on a essayé de calmer le jeu en
entendant le jeu de cette
mouvance en pensant qu'il y en a qui
disent oui il faut démocratiser
les islamistes est il obligé les
démocrates y avait quelqu'un qui est
venu me réciter ça chez moi de la part
d'un premier ministre
j'ai les presque mis à la porte et donc
vous parler des choses que moi j'ai une
déclaration de monsieur mouche qui
disait clairement ceci j'ai besoin du
fils à la rançon sa tête évidemment le
fils qui permettrait de balayer
ce qu'il considérait être des
adversaires de son programme dans le fln
est encore une fois une fois que ces
éléments seraient éliminés on se
débarrasserait des fils les choses se
sont passées différemment
le fils n'a pas de programme politique
très élaboré
c'est son discours contestataire qui
séduit les prêches à l'intérieur des
mosquées même sur les places publiques
résonne chaque jour comme des meetings
les premières élections libres depuis
l'indépendance sont pour joint 90 il ne
s'agit encore que d'élections
municipales
mais le test va être décisive
certains leaders s'inquiètent déjà de la
poussée islamiste
[Musique]
les partis laïcs comme le rcd et la
gauche tiennent meeting devant des
foules clairsemé et c'est un coup de
tonnerre au soir des résultats
plus d'un électeur sur deux a voté pour
le fisc les islamistes remporté plus de
800 communes et même de grandes villes
comme alger oran et constantine
les partis d'opposition autre que le
fils sont laminés l'ouverture
démocratique laisse finalement deux
adversaires face à face les islamistes
et le pouvoir
corrompt à ce titre on était là à
daloa favelas l'accord de ouaga dona
benta connaît l'intérêt
nous expliquions ces différents éléments
les différents éléments du projet était
musulman donc la liberté la dignité
l'équité la justice absolument et puis
le contrôle du peuple
cette possibilité que n'avait pas eu le
peuple jusqu'à présent de sanctionner le
pouvoir mise en place
[Musique]
dans les communes gagné par les
islamistes le nouvel ordre moral se met
en place à bordj une ville de l'est
algérien le fils a fermé d'autorité la
salle de la cinémathèque
des artistes furieux sont descendus
d'alger pour faire ouvrir le cinéma
les nouveaux élus n'en démordent pas
plus question de proposer à l'écran des
films occidentaux
contraires à la morale islamique
il ya ici de
cinéma
cinémas jay z
qui résident à vue il mettra le
camion mais modérée la piste à la
cinémathèque de plusieurs variables et
la villette boyd cinématiques
aussi on n'est pas là pour fermer les
cinémas depuis
il a été décidé pour contourner décider
où les directeurs mais tant qu'il ya la
richesse c'est lui qui décide de
l'avenir
en angola le maccabi le cadre concernant
le challenge d'hiver mr iphone arbitre
le faut on saura quoi faire au niveau
canadien venait genre de film
on sait ce que c'est on sait ce que
c'est
comme chez les
autres
les
routiers des coûts non ferreux de matt
ellis leur soi disant
pour beaucoup le végétalisme et vous
verrez comment l'éducation du beau
cinéma trouvez vous verrez qu'ils mènent
toujours la télévision vous m'avez dit
de venir ici pour tenir une discussion
franche et honnête sur la culture vous
m'avez andry gâtez vous m'avez fait un
discours politique je trouve que vous
n'avez pas été honnête avec moi
personnellement point la livre ça est
trop sympa de comme moi je montais
[Musique]
pour le fils la marche vers le pouvoir
est ouverte
nous sommes au printemps 91
quelques mois auparavant
la guerre du golfe à galvaniser les
militants dans d'énormes manifestations
le prochain rendez vous capital ce sont
les élections législatives à venir là où
le pouvoir peut basculer du côté des
islamistes le gouvernement sentant le
danger à découper la carte électorale de
façon grossière abassi madani répond par
une grève insurrectionnelle
il ordonne office de paralyser tout le
pays
les premiers jours les islamistes
déferlent dans les grandes villes
[Applaudissements]
madani exige maintenant des élections
présidentielles il a sans doute en tête
le scénario iranien
comme en iran le pouvoir est honni par
le peuple comme en iran il devrait
tomber comme un fruit mûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant les lie les quinze jours de
grève nous avons travaillé
avec le gouvernement jusqu'à la dernière
minute
c'est à dire que le savez à quel moment
j'ai eu à agir pour l'état de siège pas
ce qu'ils veulent dans après la décision
dépend de sièges j'ai d'abord reçu un
coup de fil de boire à bord chef du
gouvernement me disant textuellement
serralde à toi de jouer
en coulisses un bras de fer se joue
entre l'armée et le gouvernement des
formateurs le premier ministre à moosch
joue la montre voyons que la grève du
fils s'essouffle mais le général nos
âmes ne l'entend pas de cette oreille la
répression s'abat par surprise faisant
des dizaines de morts les places sont
reprises une ayew pour le fils c'est un
échec cuisant
l'armée accusés chez blier le
gouvernement de complaisance à l'égard
du fils le premier ministre bruce se
justifie quelques années plus tard sur
la chaîne al-jazira
[Musique]
je battais intraday quand on parle
évidemment beaucoup menti mensah siassia
au canada la
dca loi la décale vers
9h15 au comoedia léo cometti le titre
solabios la cour mably batterie iv what
i'm not about what about all
work and i des mâts
canada
état de siège couvre-feu les militaires
concentre désormais l'essentiel du
pouvoir le printemps démocratique par
lequel le fils est engouffré n'aura duré
qu'un an et demi les islamistes ont
perdu une bataille mais le nouveau
premier ministre aux ali se retrouve
d'entrée confronté aux fils
j'avais dit à l'époque à 2,6 madani j'ai
été nommé pour organiser des élections
législatives
avant la fin de l'année et je m'engage à
changer la loi scélérate qu'elle était
faite loin de découpage de charcutage et
je m'engage à faire des élections
propres et honnêtes en est pour
une part
il m'avait posé à quai samedi et les
élections présidentielles je lui avais
10 d'exo présidentielle ce n'est pas de
mes prérogatives allé voir le président
de la république
j'ai dit que ma mission n'était pas de
tuer le fils et c'est une année
mais que à titre fraternelle
je lui ai indiqué
alu et emballage que le maire moyens de
conduire à la destruction de fils c'est
de continuer la pratique de la violence
dans la rue royale
c'est l échec personnel pour les
dirigeants du fis ce film est ici dans
leur dernier face à face avec la presse
walla
par année
pour taper le film noir qui perd à
paris à tout va non mais hulu je ne
devienne pas naples levinas kadhafi
voilà nous l'a dit madame
hadja dessus mais moi ça fait tout
oneaccess colonna
qui le dit mais un même outil va aller
coût social film justin
timberlake ou tu vas aller comme ça ce
film celle ci échappe un petit tube
coutume à américaine oui mais il habille
la dette
il l'habitude leur
jeu comme à dire combien
la
misère ou tel - teddy ou dire qu en
termes de commandes militaires à mon
frère comme la loi un accord d'allouer
mais ça mérite qu'on leur portait
michael schumacher 1 km ce matin la vie
semblait aussi je suis aux
quart ou menara tant mieux ou sliimy il
n'empêche la main gauche il a dit cela
dit leur vider le cache
pas rouvrir
mardi qu'elle n'avait que douze autres
foulards
nous n'allons même
avis que la mort de bach m une façon
keller montmagny aoula
al islami un feu de la st le manège
était
tout à
fait normal mais richert lequel il n'a
pas dit s'il est
bloqué du monde à paris
mais si votre
budget
le mieux est touché mais je vois
missouri
où le deal était une équipe
en menaçant d'en appeler à la guerre
sainte belhadji madani commettent une
erreur politique
l'armée les jette en prison tous les
deux peu de temps après cette conférence
ils vont y rester toute la durée du
conflit le maire d'alger kamel guemazi
et d'arrêter en même temps le fils
viennent de perdre ses principaux
dirigeants
on nous a introduits je réponds que en
général c'est une adressé sept chefs
d'accusation chacun vont être passible
de la peine de mort
atteinte à la sûreté de l'état
destruction de l'économie nationale bref
des accusations connues dans l'histoire
ensuite nous avons été conduit à la
prison de blida où j'ai purgé une peine
de trois ans et trois mois
et qu'elle était à ce moment là leur
état d'esprit et leur ligne de défense à
madani et belhadj je crois que à ce
moment là ils pensaient que il
représentait le peuple c'est eux le
peuple donc ils prennent des décisions
au nom du peuple il pensait que le
peuple était avec eux et qui s'il y
avait des élections ce n'était pas la
peine de prendre le pouvoir par la force
mais qui le prenaient par la voix de de
la démocratie et des élections
vous savez le france en 1117 un franc et
donc il y à des expressions diverses
dans le tarn et
ma le tarn et était l'une des
expressions elles étaient très
minoritaires mais elle existait elle
existait comme elle existe toujours dans
partout dans tous les mouvements
bon à l'époque
c'est à dire que à l'époque ont chacun
moi j'étais à l'étranger
j'ai d'ailleurs juste une sortie
d'algérie sur recommandation du jir
abassi madani ciblage à qui j'ai demandé
est ce que je dois rester au sortir au
mois de mai didot de sortir de faire le
tour de du monde d'expliquer ce qui
s'est passé de de dire au monde
de m annuler
l'identité véritable des tenants du
régime de la sécurité militaire algérien
des souffrances du peuple algérien tout
pour faire un tour d'information à
travers le monde à cette époque le fils
a décidé à la majorité de continuer à
jouer la carte des élections mais ce
dirigeant pousse déjà la lutte armée il
est très proche des réseaux afghans il
fallait se préparer il fallait certes
été contre toute tentative de vouloir
provoquer mais j'étais pour une
préparation au cas où
ils se passeraient ce qui s'est passé
après
nous avions le sentiment que le fils
avait adopté une logique de l' escalade
saïdi le nom à l'affrontement armé d'un
marteau nana représente une autre
tendance islamiste dit modéré avec son
parti il a choisi d'islamiser petit à
petit la société quitte à faire des
compromis avec le pouvoir fort
amis nous avons créé un parti pour
éviter à la société d'aller à
l'affrontement
pour préserver l'islam
afin qu'il ne soit pas assimilé au
terrorisme
et éviter à l'état de 10 par
elle
c'est une idéologie
fascisante c'est pas deux c'est un peu
parti musulman comme certains qui
veulent comparer au mrp
la démocratie chrétienne ça n'a rien à
voir absolument moi j'aurais bien moi je
peux me contenter comme démocrate
chrétien démocrate musulman oui après
tout je suis attaché à ma région mon
coeur je peux être démocrate chrétien
mais ces gens là furent proches
les élections législatives approchent et
le fils repart au combat au grand stade
d'alger le jeune fils d'ali belhadj
prend la relève de son père emprisonné
[Musique]
abassi madani
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont mis
un nouvel avis lequel il a payé nos
mains
[Applaudissements]
avis budget
leon powe
[Applaudissements]
leïla
le maire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 26 décembre 91 c'est le premier tour
près d'un électeur sur deux ne va pas
voter le fils a pour lui des militants
très mobilisés c'est le nombre de
participations qu'il est désert alors
chaque bureau de vote pendant le nombre
de participants est à l'arrêt comme ça
on en est partout et de sulniac aux
courses avant le pourcentage de
participation pour voies voilà à à 12
heures nous avons 160 votants
ça pourcentage de 20 et de 400 par
rapport à 7 181 inscrits
[Musique]
vanessa grave
le ministre de l'intérieur était
désespéré parce que il ne s'attendait
pas à cela et d'ailleurs il a fallu le
forcer pour aller annoncer à la salle et
votre ado les résultats indiquent que
mon chef du gouvernement mon directeur
de cabinet y aille parce qu'il dit
qu'est ce que j'ai fait au bon dieu pour
avoir la charge d'annoncer une
catastrophe pareille
profitant de l'absence ion massive luffy
sort grand vainqueur du 1er tour
le pouvoir est à portée de mains des
islamistes dans vingt jours pour le
deuxième tour ils sont assurés d'avoir
une majorité au parlement
au fln personne n'a vu venir ce
raz-de-marée tandis que dans la rue les
militants fait déjà la future république
islamique d'alger
[Musique]
dans quel état psychologique était
nécessaire de l'idée ils étaient ils
étaient il était effondré était vraiment
effondré parce que il ne s'attendait pas
encore une fois à
ce résultat on lui avait fait croire que
le frr l'aléa moral
la majorité des sièges nuance avec le
pis aller gagner nos militaires on
savait que le bus allait gagner ceux qui
ont peut-être pas dire que c'est avec
lui la chose penser qu'ils allaient
qu'il allait avoir aïe
déjà il n'allait pas avoir la majorité
mais nous on savait qu'ils partaient
avec art à dubaï on savait douanes sabeg
est allé vous dites on savait que vous
ne le dites pas au président chadli qui
croient que 70 des sièges vont aller au
fln mais je vous ai déjà envoyé un
rapport je voulais qu'on fasse moins dix
militaires va pas faire un coup d'état
moi je suis allée galice voulait pas que
je fasse un coup d'état je rencontrais
khaled nezzar après la victoire du chis
donc entraîné entre entre les deux tours
il a demandé à me voir à me voir seul il
m'a dit comment vous voyez je dis écoute
dans un premier temps on va au
deuxième tour d'ailleurs le deuxième
tour on va se dérouler vous allez voir
dans la ferveur les algériens dès que le
voleur de manière concrète de danger ils
vont s'engager je vous garantis qu'ils
ont entendu dès le lendemain du premier
tour les propos du fils qui disait ceci
nous préparons des tribunaux populaires
ceux qui refusent de se soumettre à la
loi de dieu en tendant à la droite du
fils doivent ou quitter le pays ou bien
se taire et je crois qu'il aurait fait
ils ont montré leur détermination
auparavant
se taire devant ce genre de péril ça
revenait à quelque part a cautionné
tous les clips annoncé
le compte à rebours est lancé il reste
deux semaines avant le second tour
à l'appel des km des centaines de
milliers de personnes descendre dans la
rue certains manifestants pense que
l'algérie est en danger de mort et qu'il
faut stopper le fils par tous les moyens
d'autres pensent qu'il faut aller quand
même au second tour
après une victoire du fils au premier
tour des élections législatives ils font
en 45 26% des suffrages exprimés
qu'est ce qu'on fait on est évidemment
préoccupés de la façon dont ils vont
gérer ça du point de vue français ont
mobilisé tant de savoir comment ils vont
gérer pour savoir comment on va se
positionner on peut intervenir plus
le peuple algérien avait exprimé sa
préférence et sa voix je pense qu'à ce
stade les états unis s'attendait à ce
que le processus électoral se poursuivre
jusqu'au deuxième tour
il s'attendait aussi à ce qu'il y ait
une représentation islamistes
considérable au sein du gouvernement
peuvent
nous avons parlé aux dirigeants du fils
après leur victoire leur avons dit que
les décideurs en algérie
l'europe et l'occident ne voulait pas de
la victoire des islamistes
oh là là ont ils même rang nous leur
avons dit
accepter un pourcentage de sièges mines
et refuser les autres provost nice bat
moyenne les responsables du fils nous
aurait pas
ne se conformeraient qu'aux résultats
sortiront
pas il n'allait nova il la bible était
il l'était à ba 112 la démocratie ne se
réduit pas à l'électorat lige
en croire en particulier dans le haut de
la db le nord pays occidentaux on croit
que l'élection
c'est c'est le la pierre de touche de
toute démocratie oui dans certaines
conditions qui seraient presque idéale
mais dans un pays qui est soumis à un
juge qui est soumis une sorte de vent de
sable permanent qu'est ce que vous la
collection aller au deuxième tour c'est
l'instauration d'abord de l'état
islamique et ensuite c'est là où la
guerre civile réel une guerre civile
interviendra donc d'une façon ou d'une
autre il faut trouver une autre solution
mais qu'elle c'est un dilemme comment à
trouver une autre solution pour arrêter
le processus électoral et dire y aura
pas de deuxième tour sans
violer les dispositions
constitutionnelles le 4 janvier
l'assemblée nationale termine son mandat
bon alors
des genres voire le président en lui dit
voilà la solution
la seule solution c'est que si vous
démissionnez on applique à ce moment là
ces dispositions constitutionnelles qui
va le voir eh ben c'est khaled nezzar
qui a été désigné par
ses collègues pour aller le voir
isolé à la présidence chedli hésite il
irait bien au second tour mairal
lausanne qui a l'appui de l'armée
l'obliger à démissionner les généraux
sont les maîtres d'oeuvre de ce coup de
force mais ils veulent garder des formes
le président chadli mal à l'aise devant
les caméras est obligé de sauver des
apparences
des fonctions de président de la
république dire
aujourd'hui
et j'espère
que l'opinion publique algérienne serein
apprécié cette responsabilité sa
décision je ne cherche pas à fuir mes
responsabilités bien au contraire mais
sa décision me semble indispensable vu
la difficulté la gravité de cette étape
particulière c'est pour cela que j'ai
préféré prendre cette décision pour le
bien pour l'unité pour la cohésion et la
stabilité la sécurité du pays
le parlement est dissous le deuxième
tour prévu pour le 16 janvier n'aura
jamais lieu une partie de la société
convaincu d'avoir échappé au pire ferme
les yeux sur la méthode
à l'étranger françois mitterrand proche
de chadli dénonce ce coup de force
ce qui n'a pas été accompli en cette
circonstance et jusqu'au terme prévu
devra l'être
et que les dirigeants algériens
ce nouveau en retrouvant le fils
de la démocratisation nécessaire qui
passe forcément par des élections libres
françois-mitterand juste au lendemain de
l'annulation
du
deuxième tour avait dit il faut qu' il
faut que l'algérie revient au processus
démocratique avec vous avez réagi sinon
on dit pas vis-à-vis d'un état étranger
il faut la vivre
le parlement français en 1940 dit stop
nous donnons les pleins pouvoirs à
monsieur pétain au maréchal pétain
à une majorité écrasante je me rappelle
plus des chiffres fin mais vous les avez
aussi bien que moi un colonel devenu
général
s'en va à londres et dit je n'accepte
pas je suis contre c'est
antidémocratique
puisque la majorité du peuple français
représentés au parlement à beewi ap et
un caddie l'histoire après qu'ils
avaient raison c'était peut-être illégal
mais c'était légitime le problème se
posait comme cela en algérie fallait-il
aller c'est arrivé au pouvoir un parti
qui vous disaient oui un homme une voix
mais une seule fois on n'ira pas aux
élections après parce que la démocratie
est coffré elle est impie lorsque nous
serons au pouvoir nous y resterons pour
l'éternité parce que c'est nous qui
sommes les détenteurs de la vérité
religieuse et c'est nous qui appliquera
encore est ce que vous les laisser au
nom de la démocratie
vous les laisser prendre le pouvoir
[Musique]
vous
le coup d'état a créé un tel déficit
électorale un tel déficit démocratique
que seul un historique pouvait le
compenser d'où
le choix entre mois un boudiaf bon moi
j'ai refusé le lendemain j'ai fait une
conférence de presse
à l'hôtel aurassi où j'ai dit faut
appeler un chat un chat
s'il s'agit d'un coup d'état que j'ai
parlé de la semaine à faire d'abord
j'étais malade les cds commencé à
apparaître jeter des larmes la douleur
tout cela et il fallait faire face aux
problèmes d'organisation de la b2 pour
la mise en place de l'armée au problème
politique il fallait toucher essayer de
trouver un président qu'il fallait et
puis on a essayé par tous les moyens et
puis on a pensé il ya eu l'idée qui a
germé comme ça et là des bords et après
là j'ai sauté dessus ça s'est passé dans
le salon là la décision s'est passé dans
ce cadre a un qui propose le nom fait
aller à rhodes qui a proposé le dahe moi
j'ai trouvé que c'était bonne chose
parce que je ne connaissais pas
particulièrement mais je connaissais son
histoire
boudiaf hésite refuse puis finalement se
jette dans l'arène après plus de trente
ans passés au maroc il sait que l'armée
l'appel en catastrophe pour sauver le
régime
chefs historiques du fln écarté après 62
il a une réputation d'intégrité du
diaraf a effectivement l'autorité
prestige mais il revient dans un pays
qui ne connaît plus il se retrouve
entouré de chefs de clans comme le
général bellerive ministre de
l'intérieur l'un des piliers du régime
et mohamed lamari ce général qui va
mener la guerre contre les islamistes
[Musique]
boudiaf prend la tête d'un haut comité
d'état installé en catastrophe pour
remplacer la présidence
l'algérie a foulé aux pieds sa
constitution elle va vivre plusieurs
années hors la loi
dehors le pays se referme sur le
couvre-feu l'état d'urgence est proclamé
il sera reconduit année après année
jusqu'à aujourd'hui chaque vendredi les
mosquées sont devenus des lieux
d'affrontements entre les militants du
fis ses larmes et bientôt tout
rassemblement sur internet
l'armée ratissent les quartiers
populaires des élus du fils des
militants du parti mais aussi des jeunes
arrêtés au hasard sont expédiés
directement dans des camps de
prisonniers
on nous a emmenés donc à la base
militaire de boufarik c'est une base
aérienne et de là donc on nous avait
demandé
d hercule des avions militaires de
transport et destination de suite deux
algériens notre notre hantise était que
les gens fassent des bêtises les métis à
dire aller soit agresser des militaires
soient vouloir sortir coûte que coûte et
les militaires sachant qu'ils étaient
armés on avait peur donc de tout ça et
donc on avait notre conscience nous
interdisait de laisser-faire de laisser
un pourrissement de laisser faire les
choses comme ça et donc on s'est
organisé donc on a fait plusieurs
commissions plusieurs comités on a fait
un petit collège un peu utilisé une
petite université où différentes
sciences et aient été enseigné les
sciences islamiques en premier lieu au
moins dix mille militants se retrouvent
ainsi prisonnier dans le sahara
certains vont rester quelques mois
d'autres plusieurs années sans aucune
décision de justice
le pouvoir a commis une erreur de
stratégie c'est quand van devenir les
antichambres du terrorisme
lorsque vous vivez dans un camp lorsque
vous vélo pression lorsque vous vivez
l'ingratitude lorsque vous vivez tout ça
les gens donc au fond des idées se font
des idées et prennent des décisions et
très souvent les gens se sont organisés
dans les cons pour aller au maquis par
la suite
six policiers algérois sont assassinés
dans la casbah les premiers groupes
armés commence à frapper en ville ce
sont des anciens d'afghanistan parfois
des jeunes des cités ou bien encore des
compagnons de brûlis l'émir des années
80 ces noyaux armée rempli de vitesse
les dirigeants du fils
finalement ce ne sont pas eux qui ont
repensé à cette et armée parce que
j'étais en prison je pense que ce sont
les responsables du fisc y sont restés
dehors et qui en vue la répression de 92
qui ont finalement pris les armes pour
se défendre il n'y avait pas d'autre
alternative
soissons ou bien se défendre ou bien
être tué donc entre les deux on préfère
se défendre est ce qu'on peut dire que
l'initiative de la lutte armée a échappé
aux fils
c'est à dire
une initiative dans le tarn il a échappé
pas échapper complètement mais on peut
dire qu'elle a laissé un gouffre dans
lequel elle est entrée le gia
oh
veillez en recevant la presse nationale
parlait de dialogue national est-ce que
ce dialogue irai jusqu à discuter avec
le fils ou certains de ses dirigeants
actuellement prisonniers il faut
dialoguer avec les gens qui posent le
problème de la démocratie interne au
sein en termes clairs mais pas avec des
gens qui utilisent la mitraillette et le
reste et de deux je pense que le syli à
dialogue avec la société algérienne qui
constitue dans sa grande majorité par la
jeunesse algérienne j'ai de pousser
cette jeunesse à s'organiser autour de
ses difficultés à présenter des
programmes mais je crois que c'est là le
grand dialogue du président vous avez
eue dans la version écrite de votre
discours de 10 janvier des mots
extrêmement durs contre la mafia la
corruption les prévaricateurs qui
régnait jusque hausse vers les plus
hautes de l'état est-ce que vous pouvez
changer les choses sans changer les
hommes est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya
une épuration en algérie le pouvoir sans
gaz sans dans la légalité parce que ce
qu'il faut éviter ce sont des règlements
de continuer là la patte du monde de
prendre mais le d'envoi légal tous ceux
qui sont pas capables de choses nous
allons y poursuivre et de par prendra
toutes les mesures nécessaires en vue de
ramener ses bientôt l'être
monsieur je crois vous avez encore des
questions si voter allez-y parce que je
vais arrêter parce que je pense que nous
avons fait le tour de toutes les
questions et je vous remercie beaucoup
et je vous fixe rendez vous pour l'année
prochaine pour nous expliquer merci
beaucoup
boudiaf reprend à son compte la lutte
anti islamiste engagé par l'armée le
fils est dissous quand arrive le procès
de ces dirigeants là lyria avocats des
militants des droits de l'homme défend
ali belhadj et abassi madani mais tout
est joué d'avancé devant le tribunal
militaire de blida le pouvoir condamne
les accusés à douze années de prison
les juges en algérie pour vous résumer
sont eux qui lisent le jugement ou lola
ray mais
derrière les juges c'est comme
l'algérien il y a toujours des officiers
de la sécurité militaire qui dicte le
jugement comme vous avez ailleurs le
président de la république le
gouvernement l'assemblée que nous
appelons le pouvoir apparent mais le
pouvoir et lcd décideurs de l'armée le
visa était au noir le fils a tué des à
tuer des algériens le fils utilise
la politique donc il a été jugé par les
tribunaux algériens et l'éducation ça il
faut que tu bosses de sa ild ap il n'est
pas question qui revient
boudiaf ne se contente pas d'être la
vitrine du régime il veut monter son
propre parti ils dénoncent la corruption
et prend le peuple à témoin
[Applaudissements]
les fêtes mais chouette
[Musique]
un membre de la garde présidentielle a
tiré dans le dos de boudiaf dans cette
salle d'annaba
c'est en tout cas la version officielle
quelques minutes après le drame les
algériens s'interrogent qui a voulu la
mort du président à quel secret d'état
voulait-il s'attaquer
mohamed boudiaf est resté seulement cinq
mois au pouvoir
les décideurs se retrouvent sans
solution
ils ont stoppé la course du fils mais la
violence se déchaîne un mystérieux sigle
le gia fait son apparition
les algériens sentent que leur pays sans
france dans les années les plus sombres
de son histoire
[Musique]